pourquoi le gouvernement libéral at il
autant d'argent à redistribuer quelques
mois avant les élections
regardons d'abord les dépenses des
différents ministères en arrivant au
pouvoir le gouvernement couillard a
d'abord appuyer très fort sur le frein
en matière de dépenses on est obligé de
donner un coup de frein plus fort la
croissance des dépenses est passé de 4,7
pour cent dans le budget péquiste de
2013 2014 à 1,4 puis 1,1 pour cent dans
les deux premiers budgets du
gouvernement libéral une période que
plusieurs ont qualifié d' austérité
budgétaire
une période durant laquelle beaucoup de
grogne que ce soit dans le secteur
d'éducation ou encore dans le réseau de
la santé en péril tous les réseaux
publics
[Musique]
puis à partir de 2016 des libéraux ont
commencé à utiliser cette marge de
manoeuvre les chiffres des derniers
budgets nous montrent que la croissance
des dépenses est d'abord revenu à ce
qu'elle était avant la période de
rigueur budgétaire
et depuis elle n'a cessé d'augmenter
grâce à la croissance économique
nous avons les moyens de poursuivre nos
efforts de réduction du fardeau fiscal
ce qui donne aujourd'hui encore plus de
marge de manoeuvre aux mines et des
finances et à croissance de l'économie
québécoise qui beaucoup plus importante
que ce qu'on avait estimé pour 2010 est
par exemple les ministres des finances
misait sur une croissance de 1,7 pour
cent mais en réalité le pib québécois
augmenté de 3% soit presque le double
bref en imposant d'abord une période de
rigueur budgétaire puis en profitant
ensuite d'une croissance économique plus
soutenue le gouvernement libéral dispose
d'une marge de manoeuvre pour
redistribuer les millions quelques mois
avant les élections
[Musique]
et